on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis né baptisé ne rentrent et
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre émission
le petit émir pour ceux d'entre vous qui
auraient raté les deux premiers épisodes
nous vous rappelons que nous suivons
durant cette saison toutes les étapes de
la création d'une pièce de théâtre par
une troupe de comédiens porteurs de
handicap lors du précédent épisode
nous avons suivi marica la metteuse en
scène en pleine séance de casting avec
les pensionnaires de la maison d'accueil
spécialisée de sainte suzanne nous
avions alors fait la connaissance de
flavie ingrid mathias et leurs amis
cette fois ci nous vous proposons de
découvrir le casting mené à lire sam de
la ressource avec maureen émis florian
thomas et kevin cet atelier mime est
animée par jean michel et danielle
harton à leur rencontre
donc je vous présente
marie cap donc elle est là pour voir
comment vous
le théâtre le même ok je suis genlis à
louer
éducateur spécialisé du centre de la
ressource donc je travaille avec des
jeunes au collège à trier internes ou
des jeunes plein de vie plein de
vitalité et là d'un coup c'est un
atelier qui a permis vraiment une belle
rencontre autour d'une médiation tel que
le mime c'est vraiment le plaisir de
jouer ensemble et c'est ce que les
jeunes nous montre dans ses ateliers
c'est qu'ils prennent vraiment de
plaisir et vous verrez les sourire sur
leur visage et leur motivation à
construire ensemble un jeu scénique qui
est pour moi d'une grande qualité et qui
permet d'exprimer énormément de choses
avec très peu de moyens finalement et
surtout avec l'expression de leur corps
et ils nous font découvrir un autre
monde le monde du silence et le monde du
mime et ça c'est génial
bonjour je m'appelle daniel muya et je
suis éducatrice spécialisée en formation
j'interviens au quotidien auprès de
personnes en difficulté notamment auprès
de jeunes en situation de handicap je
coanime avec jean-michel ou et l'atelier
mime auprès d'adolescents sourds et
malentendants j'apprends beaucoup
puisque en fait je suis aussi amené à a
lâché prise en fait t'as oublié mon
masque à délirer avec eux à communiquer
différemment à apprendre de nouvelles
techniques et c'est ça qui est vraiment
très intéressant dans mon métier
place maintenant à l'indispensable
échauffement corporel et vocal
non c'est pas possible de travers c'est
pas possible
bravo et bon qui commençait maintenant
donc dans cet atelier c'était très riche
aussi très physique très plus corporels
pour moi et c'était intéressant de voir
aussi la leur capacité à s'exprimer
malgré leur handicap sourd et muet et
voilà c'est vraiment un univers on
découvre et on rentre dedans parce qu'il
nous ouvre la porte et c'était vraiment
très très riche
marica et jean-michel vont alors proposé
aux élèves de monter sur scène pour
miner un automobiliste en totale
improvisation
sauront-ils les surprendre
oui
la vàd au masters
m
hong kong
à
c'est maintenant l'heure du bilan marica
et jean-michel ont ils été séduits dans
leurs propositions ils ont fait un
exercice donc sur la voiture qui
toussaint du mime et dans le spectacle
comme ça se passe sur le paris-dakar
j'aimerais bien qu'ils continuent à
travailler ça et l'intégrer au spectacle
cirque on voit sur sur le sur scène d'un
des gens qui font le paris dakar et qui
s'expriment aussi avec leur corps et qui
est voilà donc on a trouvé une bonne
idée pour en termes de mise en scène et
de vieux
kevin aujourd'hui tu as aimé
bien
mais quoi
voiture on a fait le match
la voiture fait bien et bien voilà
c'était le troisième épisode en
compagnie des élèves de lire sam de la
ressource un nouveau talent pour la
troupe at il été détectée vous le saurez
en regardant les épisodes suivants la
prochaine émission vous emmènera à l'ime
de la montagne pour un atelier très
percutant en compagnie d'hélène et de
ses élèves à très bientôt donc